in the comments because a little bit
later on pretty tells going to be giving
a statement about that rwanda flight and
that will be the first opportunity we
have to really take the temperature on
where tory back benches are on pulling
out of the european uh convention on
human rights and now that seemed to be
floated by the prime minister yesterday
uh you have uh some tory mps uh doubling
down on that going public i've just been
talking to greg smith the buckingham mp
who says that that's uh what ought to
happen uh now danny's strictly nervous
about picking a a second big fight about
a completely separate institution from
the european union but nevertheless one
uh with europe in its title uh so an
important day in the commons will
will understand some of the mood very
shortly i think yeah and interesting you
did that you know whether or not the the
mood in the country which which appears
quite divided about that that rwanda
flights is echoed in the house um
and in in terms of rwanda are we
expecting that that statement straight
after prime minister's questions from
the home secretary uh pretty much um
there's been quite a lot of backwards
and and forwards on that today uh at one
point it was off then it was uh on again
but i think we are now getting it the
government taking a funny attitude to
the commons normally things meant to be
announced uh discussed in the commons
when it came to uh that brexit northern
ireland protocol they avoided the
comments on monday but it seems like
they're not taking that approach today
which is being held at seminary
today at one o'clock to commemorate the
40th anniversary the end of the
falklands war i hope as many members as
possible will be able to attend
i'd also like to point out that
just a minute to apologize
i'd also like to point out not this time
the sign language interpreter
yeah a bit of housekeeping going on
there uh before prime minister's
questions at lindsay hall just uh
encouraging mps to come back to the
house at four o'clock
[Music]
mr speaker this morning i had meetings
with ministerial colleagues and others
in addition to my duties in this house i
shall have further such meetings later
today
my word
government support for households is
greatly appreciated but high energy
costs are also causing massive problems
for businesses and particularly energy
intense manufacturing
will the prime minister support the
repairing the black countries to fact by
the left and by andy street to reduce
reliance on fossil fuels and will he
meet with me to look at how the black
country can be a pilot project to
decarbonize reduce costs and project
protect the region's manufacturing jobs
well i thank my honourable friend he's a
great uh champion for dudley and for the
black country and in addition to the
twelve hundred pounds uh for the eight
million most vulnerable households that
were providing four hundred pounds to
help everybody with the cost of uh of
energy mr speaker we're supporting the
black country uh with cost efficient
energy infrastructure and uh the region
has already received 1.5 million to
develop a cluster plan for
decarbonisation we now come to the
leader of the opposition pierre
stabber you mr speaker
uh
can i can i pay tribute to all those who
served in the falklands
my uncle was among them serving on the
hms antelope when it went down
thankfully he made it back
but too many serving in that war didn't
and we remember them all
mr speaker britain is set for lower
growth
than every major economy
except russia
why
prime minister
this is mr speaker
i'll i'll tell him uh mr speaker
actually uh we are going to have
according to the imf and the oecd we are
in addition to the fastest growth in the
g7 last year we're gonna have the second
fastest have the second fastest this
year and we will return to the top of
the table mr speaker but the reason mr
speaker uh other countries are
temporarily moving it is of course
because we came out of the pandemic
faster than they did
because we took the right decisions to
come out to come out of lockdown which
he opposed mr speaker and that's why
right now mr speaker we have the highest
number of people on payroll employment
on record
[Applause]
mr speaker he always likes to blame
global forces but global forces are just
that global everybody faces them
britain isn't prison under crippling
economic sanctions
like russia
no wonder he doesn't want to answer the
question why is the uk set for lower
growth than every other major economy
mr speaker i i think i think everybody
can see that i've just answered the
question
what once once again once again he's get
he's guilty of what uh my legal friends
call ignoratio elenkai he's failed uh
he's failed to listen to what i've
actually said uh mr speaker what would
be useful in supporting the uk economy
right now would be if the leader of the
labour party ended his sphinx-like
silence about the rmt's strikes coming
up in the course of the next couple of
weeks
will he will he now
will he now break with his shadow
transport secretary and denounce
labour's rail strikes
he's in government
just to remind the prime minister he
seems to have gone his prime minister's
question opposition
he's in government
he could do something to stop the
strikes
but he hasn't lifted a finger
i don't want the strikes to go ahead but
he does
he wants
mr speaker
he wants the country to grind to a halt
so he can feed off the division
and as as
mr speaker as for his boasting about the
economy
he thinks he can perform jedi mind
tricks on the country
these are the droids you're looking for
no rules were broken the economy is
booming
the problem is the force just isn't with
him anymore
[Applause]
he thinks he's obi-wan kenobi
the truth is he's jabber the heart
last week
last week he stood there and boasted
that we would continue to grow the
economy this week it turns out the
economy shrank for the second month in a
row how does it help britain to have an
ostrich prime minister with his head in
the sand
[Applause]
there he goes again mr speaker running
running this country down uh when
when everybody we've got we've got the
highest we've got the highest employment
highest input
look i want to hear the questions and
the answers and
whether you like it but i genuinely
believe it the public who watch it also
wants to hear both prime minister
i mean mr speaker we've got lower
unemployment in france germany italy
canada uh we've got that we've got the
highest on people in payroll jobs as
i've just said and 620 000 more since uh
since records began uh and he might like
to know this uh that just in the first
five months of this year this country
has attracted i think 16 billion pounds
of investment in its tech sector
he doesn't like these european
comparisons let's make it for him three
times as much as germany twice as much
as france mr speaker he should be
talking this country up not running it
down
that's the ostrich
he's not just denying how bad things are
he's actively making things worse
his 15 tax rises are throttling growth
and the director of the cbi is so fed up
he's reduced to saying can we stop
operation say big dog
and move to action stations on the
economy
mr speaker we know what the prime
minister says about british business in
private
i think that's pretty um parliamentary
but when did screwing business turn from
a flippant comment into economic policy
well mr speaker i just i just reminded
the house of what's happening in uh in
tech week uh in this country the massive
investment that's coming in uh helped by
the way by this
130 percent super deduction for business
investment that my right old friend uh
the chancellor has put in never forget
mr speaker that labor under under labour
taxes go up on businesses and on people
and we're cutting we're not only putting
1200 more into people's pockets we're
having a tax cut worth 330 pounds he
talks about taxes 330 pounds on average
for everybody who pays national
insurance
labor have already made spending
commitments in this parliament alone
worth 94 billion pounds more than the
government that's 2 100 pounds for every
household in the country mr speaker no
wonder no labour government has ever
left office with unemployment lower than
when they came in
mr speaker 15 tax rises and we're sacked
for the highest tax burden since
rationing
he says the economy is booming when it's
shrinking he's he's game playing so much
he thinks he's on love island
trouble is
prime minister i'm reliably informed
that contestants that give the public
the ick get booted out
and it's it's not just low growth he's
also lost control of inflation he was
warned about this last september and
what did he do
he dismissed it he didn't act he sat on
his hands
now prices are through the roof
and we're set to have the highest
inflation in the g7
when will he accept he got it badly
wrong when he claimed that worries about
inflation were unfounded
[Applause]
mr speaker we're helping people with the
cost of living with 1200 pounds on the
14th of july the money will be going
into people's bank accounts why can we
do that mr speaker because we have the
fiscal firepower to do it uh because the
economy is in robust shape uh with
record numbers of people in payroll
employment uh mr speaker and that is
thanks to the steps that we took that he
continuously opposed and if he wants to
i just remind mr speaker he has a chance
i won't say this interrogatively he has
the chance now to clear it up
he can oppose the labour's rail strikes
right now safe
he can he can disagree he can disagree
and give him that opportunity let him
disagree with the union barons who would
add to people's costs in the coming
weeks
[Music]
mr speaker i don't want the strikes to
go ahead he does so he can feed on the
division
[Applause]
mr speaker
mr speaker they may they're making a lot
of noise now but i've got a long list
here of what his mps really think of him
yeah drag dragging everyone down who
said that come on
who was it said that
authority authority is destroyed come on
hands up
which of you was it
come on
cons
can't win back trust anybody owning up
you're very quiet now hands hands
mr speaker mr speaker
my
my personal favorite my personal
favorite is this this is a document
document circulated by his back bench in
which they call him
the conservative corbyn
prime minister i don't think that was
intended as a compliment
week after week
week after week
he stands there
and spouts the same nonsense the economy
is booming
everything's going swimmingly the people
should be grateful but whilst he's
telling britain that we never had it so
good millions of working people and
businesses know the reality
britain's growth is going to be slower
than our competitors and our inflation
higher
a prime minister who sounds totally
deluded totally failing on the economy
failing
i think we need to get to the question
but in the
but i'll just remind you i will hear the
end of the question in silence any more
noise in this corner it'll be another
cup of tea early if we're not careful
a prime minister sounds totally deluded
totally failing the economy
failing to tackle inflation
failing to back business failing to help
working people through the crisis
and mr speaker
his big idea
go back to imperial measurements
he's got 80s inflation
70s stagnation now he wants 60s weights
to complete the set
when is he going to ditch the gimmicks
and face up to reality so under him
britain's economy is going backwards
[Applause]
let's see the prime minister prime
minister
a couple of quick points about uh uh mr
corbin uh right over for instance north
uh first of all he tried repeatedly uh
to get him elected as prime minister
[Applause]
secondly speaking speaking from the
experience
he's relatively he's relatively dynamic
uh by comparison with the right
honourable gentleman
mr speaker dynamic and go here might be
hopefully speak to me i'm struggling to
hear because of the noise on both sides
so please you can if you if you if you
look to the chair it'll be easy for both
of us but what we're going to get on and
do mr speaker continue to take the tough
decisions to take this country forward
and uh decisions that are on the side of
the british people mr speaker
they're blatantly on the side of the rmt
union barons
when when there are some ticket offices
that barely sell one ticket per hour uh
mr speaker we are on the side of the
traveling uh public
by the way he hasn't mentioned this but
they're on the side of the people
traffickers who have risked people's
lives and see mr speaker and we we are
on the side of people who come here
safely and legally safely and legally mr
speaker they cop and
snipe from the sidelines that's what
they've always done we take the big
decisions to take this country forward
and no matter how much willy no matter
how much willing his right honourable
friend the deputy leader may ask him to
apply it doesn't matter how much willie
he potentially when that welly mr
speaker is always on the left foot
[Applause]
many
areas like mine have already had massive
new housing development with no
commensurate increase in general
practice sorry sorry sorry sorry point
of order and the other lady's been here
for so long she should also know that
punch water can only come at the end
it's andrew's thing
oh dear
oh dear
many areas
[Applause]
have a conversation later but certainly
it's not
reliable
many areas like mine have already had
massive new housing development with no
commensurate increase in general
practice capacity
in one of my surgeries with double the
recommended number of patients per gp
a bowel cancer diagnosis of a 51 year
old father of four
was missed and is now terminal
getting this right is a life and death
issue so will the prime minister make
sure that areas that parts of the
country that have already had massive
new housing growth get the commensurate
increase in general practice capacity
that is only right and fair prime
minister yes mr speaker and of course
we've increased the numbers of doctors
by six thousand other twelve hundred and
more gps since uh this time last year
eleven 11 800 more nurses but we must
make sure uh that areas particularly
where uh areas of new sensitive
development is going in uh that uh there
are the infrastructure services
particularly medical services uh that
they need uh the nhs has a statutory
duty to take account of population
growth i know he's met my other friends
uh the health secretary i will take it
up personally uh to make sure we get a
proper approach uh to i think a very
very important uh issue in blackfood
thank you mr speaker can i join you and
others that are remembering today the
falcons conflict of 40 years ago and
those like my colleague keith brown has
got his justice minister that served
there and in particular our thoughts
were those that paid the ultimate
sacrifice
mr speaker
yesterday our first minister started a
national conversation
on spotless right to choose an
independent future
when you look at nations like iceland
ireland norway and denmark
it is clear that our neighbors are
outperforming the united kingdom they
deliver greater income equality lower
poverty rates higher productivity social
mobility and business investment mr
speaker the list goes on and on the
evidence is overwhelming
scotland is being held back by
westminster
prime minister
all those countries can use the powers
of independence to create wealthier
fairer and greener societies why not
scotland
prime minister well mr speaker i don't i
don't uh doubt uh my my right honourable
friends talents as a conversationalist
but i think there are other subjects in
the national conversation right now
and and they include uh mr speaker what
we're doing to come through the
aftershocks of
uh with the strongest jobs led uh
recovery uh of any european economy as i
said 620 000 more people across the
whole of the uk uh mr speaker in payroll
employment than there were before the
pandemic uh began and i think another
subject of national conversation is
investment into our whole country
investment in scotland investment across
the whole of the uk as i mentioned
already in the tech center and the whole
of the uk standing strong together on
the international stage and sticking up
for the ukrainians i think that's some
of the things that the country is also
talking about mr speaker prime minister
stronger together there's a prime
minister seen the pound i think the
financial markets are giving a judgment
on this prime minister
mr speaker
the prime minister can afford to live in
his own little world his own little
britain but people have to live with the
reality of a failing westminster system
a cost of living crisis worse in the uk
than any other g7 company
an inflation rate double that of france
the second worst economic growth
forecast in the g20 next to only
sanctioned russia and now a threat of a
trade war with our european friends
triggered by a law-breaking prime
minister that is not a vision for the
future of scotland our nation is big
enough rich enough and smart enough
isn't it the case prime minister that
scotland simply can't afford to remain
trapped in the failing westminster
system
mr speaker stop the world scotland wants
to get on
minister
mr speaker i think that uh the the
figures speak for themselves the uk has
uh record numbers of people in uh
payroll employment that's a that's an
astounding thing uh when you consider
where we were during the pandemic that
was because of the uk working well
together as he will remember with the
vaccine rollout with the testing which
scotland and the rest of the country
cooperated brilliantly and uh mr speaker
he talks about a trade war he talks
about he talks about a a trade war what
could be more foolish mr speaker than a
project that actually envisages trade
barriers within parts of the united
kingdom that's what we're trying to
break down
tracy thank you uh mr speaker
during the jubilee celebrations i was
honored to share part of them with
cohort four an inspirational mentoring
and support group who provide
life-changing support to a wide range of
women such as those who've tragically
been the victim of domestic violence
sexual abuse or suffer from mental
health difficulties sadly as a result of
the panic pandemic the need for these
services only grown so would the prime
minister join me in thanking beverly and
her team for the incredible work that
they do at cohort for and set out what
more government can do to support these
organizations so they can continue to
deliver the vital care to vulnerable men
and women across all of our
constituencies
[Applause]
i thank my honourable friend i want to i
want to
extend my thanks also to beverly and
everybody in cohort 4 for what they're
doing there's the extra support that
we're giving uh includes 140 million
pounds of funding for uh victims uh
services uh and 47 uh million ring fence
particularly for organizations uh such
as cohort four uh thank you to cohort
for uh and
similar organizations for everything
that they do ed
thank you mr speaker can i join the
prime minister and lead the opposition
in paying tribute to our armed forces
and sending our thanks and gratitude to
the veterans of the falcons war and
their families
mr speaker millions of families across
our country are suffering because of the
cost of living emergency
and people in rural areas are especially
hurting
bearing the brunt of record fuel price
rises
the rural fuel duty relief scheme is
supposed to help
by taking money off the price of petrol
but some rural counties aren't eligible
like cumbria
like shropshire
and like devon
mr
mr speaker the conservative parties want
to hear ideas to help those people i
think the people of devon will note
because there are families and
pensioners across rural counties who are
missing out on this support
so mr speaker
as petrol prices saw
will the prime minister accept our idea
to help people in rural counties and
expand rural fuel duty relief
and minister
mr speaker we cut fuel duty uh for
everybody across the country by record
sums he talks about pensioners mr
speaker we're giving 850 pounds more to
every pensioner across the country and
uh he talks about the cost of energy
everybody is going to get another 400
pounds uh to help them uh with the costs
of energy and uh the great the blissful
fact about the liberal democrats is
because people don't actually know what
their policies are and
they're able to go around the country
they're able to go around the country
bamboozling the the rural communities
not revealing that they're in fact in
favor of massive new green taxes mr
speaker
which is what they want and not
revealing that they would like to go
back straight away into the common
agricultural policy and with all the
bureaucracy and all the costs that that
entails they don't say that on the
doorstep mr speaker
thank you very much mr speaker there are
proposals for up to ten thousand housing
units on flood prone green field sites
uh to the west of ifield in my
constituency that would also represent
intolerable pressure on local services
can i have an assurance from the prime
minister that as we update planning
legislation we will enshrine the
brownfield principle first for new
developments and save our environments
and our services
prime minister uh my older friend is
completely right and uh we encourage the
the use of suitable a brownfield land
and our policy is for brownfield first
everywhere and always still handbag
thank you mr speaker and the prime
minister will know from my recent
correspondence that my concordia
accounting bid constituent ruth
cicarello is the sister of jim fitton
who is currently imprisoned in iraq
and centres to 15 years for collecting
some shards of pottery um the judge
passing sentence did not believe that mr
fitton had any criminal intent and this
is obvious and significant implications
for jim and his loved ones so i would
ask the prime minister if he would be
willing to meet with me and other mps
who have constituents in jim's family to
discuss this case so that we can work in
concert to
resolve some of those issues
well i'm really grateful for the
honourable champion for raising mr
fitton's case and i have a great deal of
sympathy i must say uh with him i'll
make sure that he gets uh uh the right
might run for general gets a meeting
with the relevant minister as far as
soon as possible
thank you mr speaker one of my youngest
constituents little nelly ogshot is two
years old and has been diagnosed with
metachromatic leukodystrophy
her very brave parents
megan and tom
are supporting a campaign
to see mld added to the newborn
bloodspot
test
had that been included
in the test nelly's condition could be
treated
now the family are squaring up to
palliative care
and planning to make every day count
will the prime minister give his support
to add mld
to this hill prick test
so that families
in the future can be spared this same
heartbreak
[Music]
i i thank her very much and i know that
the thoughts of everybody will be with
nelly and her parents tom and and megan
in a a very very difficult time and uh
what i can tell her is that uh the the
national screening committee has
received a request uh to look again at
the uh conditions for uh doing an mld
test and that is currently being uh
reviewed uh right now but i will make
sure that she gets a meeting as soon as
possible with the relevant minister
there's twist
mr speaker in just five days
rail passengers across the uk and in the
northeast will be facing huge disruption
[Applause]
but on the eve
on the eve
of the biggest rail dispute in a
generation it's emerged that ministers
have not held any talks
whatsoever
[Applause]
so mr speaker i asked the prime minister
i asked the prime minister
has he
met with trade unions and employers in
the rail industry to attempt to bring
this dispute to an end
[Applause]
mr speaker i noticed i noticed that what
the
one union one union baron was asked
about this he said i don't negotiate
with the tory government is what he said
that's that's that's what they said mr
speaker we all know we all know how much
money the labor front bench taking the
rmt mr speaker we know we know why
they're sitting on their hands and
during labour's rail strikes they should
come out and condemn it mr speaker
thank you mr speaker today is pension
credit awareness day pension credit is
currently underclaimed around a quarter
of those entitled don't claim it so all
my right honourable friend join me in
encouraging people in goodling and
throughout the country to check their
eligibility make that claim so we can
get more money into the pockets of
pensioners
because a very very worthwhile important
campaign that my honourable friend uh
supports too many pensioners fail to
take up uh their entitlements under
pension credit uh it can be worth
another three thousand and three hundred
pounds a year and the more we can do to
make pensioners aware of it the better
anna macmillan thank you
why is it that the worst people often
rise to the highest office
and stay there not my words
about the prime minister
but those of his newest appointment
his cost of living czar
families across cardiff north crippled
with skyrocketing bills unable to afford
even the most basic necessities all
agree with him saying this prime
minister has to go
so if his own czar doesn't even have
faith in him tell me why those
struggling should
[Applause]
mr speaker uh
she's asked that question repeated but
let me just remind her
that this is a government that gets on
and delivers on our promises to the
people and in particular getting brexit
done i read i read the other day mr
speaker that she wants to go back into
the single market and into the customs
union
i think she i that's if that's the real
policy of the labour party mr speaker uh
going back into the eu then why won't
the shadow uh why weren't the leader of
the opposition admitted
thank you very much mr speaker when our
family adopted my two brothers in the
1980s support for adopters whether that
be financial therapeutic or professional
was minimal and by the time i became a
family law barrister in the late 1990s
it really wasn't much better effort
since particularly the adoption support
fund from 2015 onwards has improved the
situation but as ever there's much more
that we can do and to that end would my
right honourable friend look at making
self-employed adopters eligible for
statutory adoption pay so they can also
have a better and fairer start to family
life
prime minister uh
mr speaker i thank my uh honorable
friend and he's a great champion for uh
for adopters and all those who uh help
give uh children a loving and stable
home uh we've so far focused on
supporting he's quite right focus on
supporting uh employed uh parents uh but
local authorities do have the power to
provide discretionary payments
equivalent uh to maternity allowance for
self-employed adopters as well very
mccarthy yeah yeah thank you mr speaker
we know that at times of economic
hardship suicide rates are likely to
rise too we saw that after the 2008
crash so as well as doing more to
support people through the cost of
living crisis will the prime minister
commit to doing more to support
excellent suicide prevention campaigns
like calm the campaign against living
miserably and also implement labour's
pledge that anyone in need of it should
be able to access mental health
counselling within a month and then to
waiting lists
uh she's she's entirely right mr speaker
and we must uh focus uh ever more on
mental health that's why we're putting
another 2.3 billion pounds into
supporting mental health services
including uh suicide prevention and the
many wonderful uh charities that help uh
people uh with their uh with their
conditions mr speaker uh and you know
what i can say is it would be a good
thing if across the floor of this house
we had support for the spending that
we're putting in david jones
thank you mr speaker the conflict in
ukraine and the consequent disruption of
the supply chain in wheat
has highlighted the need for the united
kingdom to become more self-sufficient
in food the genetic technology bill
which has a second reading this
afternoon
will help create the conditions to
enable english farmers to produce more
food of higher quality but does my right
honourable friend agree
that the drive to self-sufficient
self-sufficiency requires a uk-wide
effort
and will he urge the devolved
administrations to adopt the provisions
of the bill
so that farmers across britain can
produce the food that the country needs
prime minister uh my honourable friend
is completely right that apparently the
policy of course uh the bill only
applies to england he's completely right
but in a in a loving and sharing way in
allah loving and sharing way we are
going to work with uh the devolved
administrations uh mr speaker so that
the whole of the uk can uh enjoy the
benefits very challenging
mental health support is vital for
victims of sexual crimes when a
rotherham survivor who's here today
reported her childhood reviews to the
police they told her not to go for
counselling as it could be used against
her in court
your attorney general is challenging the
rules so it's even easier for defence
teams to access victims counselling
notes having an immediate chilling
effect
survivors shouldn't be forced to choose
between their mental health and justice
prime minister please stop this yes
well i'm very interested to hear what
she says and i will look at the uh the
evidence that uh she has but i can and
these are very sensitive and very
difficult issues
particularly as regards uh the the
defense uh cases uh but if she looks at
what's happening for instance on uh rape
and serosexual offences where we've had
very similar problems and we are
starting to see gradually an improvement
in the in the prosecution rates and that
is because governments across across
departments across whitehall working
together to take account of victims
needs and i i i i agree the progress
isn't everything that i would like but
we are seeing progress
my right-hand friend may be aware that
the schrosberg and telford hospital
trust uh has recently submitted a
revised outline business case in support
of its 312 million pound capital
allocation made by the department of
health four years ago does he agree with
me that in order to make progress and
complete the ambitious hospital building
program the nhs decision making
processes not only need to be leveled up
they need to be speeded up
prime minister
i i think mr speaker that uh the right
honourable gentleman certainly uh speaks
for uh
many in this house in wanting faster
decisions on uh planning in the nhs but
you also and that's what we're uh we're
doing we're pushing through as he knows
uh 40 hospitals uh by the
40 hospitals we are building mr speaker
and uh what that needs is the funding
and i i just tactfully point out again
the opposition benches are bellowing
away uh they voted against the extra 39
billion they were putting in
thank you very much mr speaker
my constituent mr singh's identity has
been stolen his nhs records are being
misused but he's been advised there is
nothing the health secretary can do
crimes are being committed in his name
the home secretary's department assured
him that this would not affect his
immigration straight status
yet recently he his wife and children
were detained by uk border force whilst
traveling for a family holiday
can the prime minister explain who in
his government is responsible for this
chaotic incompetence
[Applause]
this is because i i'd be only too happy
to look at the i'm very sorry for the
experience that mr singh and his family
uh have had and i and i asked his
responsible i'm responsible speaker and
i take but i will look at the case i'll
make sure that she gets a proper answer
uh from uh from the home office in the
immigration department
theresa may
thank you
thank you mr speaker
my constituent dominique davis is the
niece of john phillips the british
journalist missing in brazil
alongside the indigenous expert bruno
pereira
will my right honourable friend ensure
that the government makes this case a
diplomatic priority
and that it works to do everything it
can to ensure that the brazilian
authorities put the resources necessary
to uncover the truth and find out what
has happened to dom and bruno
i i thank you
i thank my my right old friend very much
and i can tell i can tell her that uh
for representing the niece of uh of dom
phillips and of course like everybody in
this house we're deeply concerned about
uh what may have happened uh to him uh
fcdo officials are working closely and
now with the brazilian uh authorities
following his disappearance on the on
the fifth of june uh the minister
responsible uh has raised the issue
repeatedly uh the search and rescue
effort with uh brazil's justice and
public security minister and what we've
told the brazilians uh mr speaker is we
stand ready uh to provide a madam deputy
speaker i should say to be stand ready
to provide all the support that they may
need
thank you
point of order selane saxby thank you
madame deputy speaker i just wondered if
you could advise how i could collect the
record um for the right honourable
member for kingston and sterberton's
question well that there
former mp uh former prime minister
theresa may getting in a question just
at the end about um the family of don
phillips the british journalist missing
in south america uh but the large thrust
of what happened during prime minister's
questions about the cost of living on
this occasion and let's bring in our
deputy political editor sam coates he's
here in the studio with me uh sam uh how
did boris johnson do do you feel today
boris johnson was uh thought he might
have a bruising uh set of questions
today because it's been quite a
turbulent political time uh and uh
really
wanted to hammer the labour leader on
things like the upcoming strikes so sort
of took a swing on that trying to pin
down kierstama on whether or not he
backs uh the industrial action that's
coming pretty much next week that's
going to blight large parts of the the
country uh it wasn't one of those
premises questions uh that saw a
particular body blade for the prime
minister uh he was
essentially challenged by the leader of
the opposition on whether or not his
characterization of the economic policy
is
accurate
boris johnson likes to focus on two
different metrics one is uh the lowest
unemployment for 40 years and it is true
to say that unemployment is at record
lows uh and also the amount of
investment in the uk which he says
compares favorably to the uh european uh
uh european countries uh but i think
that particularly in light of recent
downgrades of growth forecast it's fair
to say that we're uh on calls for a
fairly uh bumpy period so the leader of
the opposition trying to highlight
perhaps what boris johnson's saying uh
with some of the other pieces of data
that are out there uh and and in terms
of kierstama's performance he was
criticized earlier in the week we saw in
the papers that some of his cabinets had
criticized him for being a bit boring in
prime minister's questions do you sense
he'd taken that to heart today
and then some jane one of one of the
most uh spectacular things uh uh at
prime minister's questions time today
was it was kierstarma wearing a massive
sign saying i'm not boring he came out
with just a series of metaphors uh
designed to absolutely disprove this
outrageous
slur
at one point he was talking about boris
johnson's jedi powers and whether or not
the drones around him all star wars uh
illusions uh uh
keith's point out uh would just parrot
the untrue things about the economy
which kierstarma uh was alleging uh that
he was saying uh then there was an
extraordinary section uh where boris
johnson where kirsten i quoted love
island um uh and he said uh on love
island contestants that get the ick get
booted out uh now i have consulted some
of the finest minds at sky news to work
out what that means uh not personally uh
being a love island aficionado um i
can't help you on it either no uh and we
and we note that uh and uh according to
uh uh according to my colleagues what
this refers to is quite suddenly no
longer fancying someone and then not
being able to remember why you ever did
in other words kirstama is using a
metaphor to try and say well the public
might have fallen in love with boris
johnson but it's now completely clear
that they don't love him and can't
remember why they ever did let's listen
to the
clip as for his boasting about the
economy
he thinks he can perform jedi mind
tricks on the country
these are the droids you're looking for
no rules were broken the economy is
booming
the problem is the force just isn't with
him anymore
[Applause]
he thinks he's obi-wan kenobi
the truth is he's jabber the heart
mr speaker we've got lower unemployment
in france germany italy canada we've got
we got the highest on people in payroll
jobs as i've just said and 620 000 more
since uh since records began uh and he
might like to know this
we're breaking away from that because
the home secretary is making a statement
about the rwanda flights
and hears that message clearly and we
are determined to deliver that
last night madam deputy speaker we aim
to relocate the first people from our
country who arrived here through
dangerous and illegal means including by
small boat
over the course of this week many and
various claims to prevent relocation
have been brought forward
now madam deputy speaker i welcome the
decisions of our domestic courts the
high court the court of appeal
and supreme court to uphold our right to
send the flight
however following a decision by an
out-of-hours judge in the european court
of human rights in strasbourg minutes
before our flight's departure the final
individuals remaining on the flight had
their removal directions paused while
their claims were considered
i want to make something absolutely
clear today imagine deputy speaker the
european court of human rights did not
rule that the policy or relocations were
unlawful
but they prohibited the removal of three
of those on last night's flight
those prohibitions
last for different time periods but are
not an absolute bar
on their transfer to rwanda
anyone who's been ordered to be released
by the courts will be tagged while we
continue to progress their relocation
while this decision by the strasbourg
court to intervene was disappointing and
surprising given the repeated and
considered judgments to the country in
our domestic cause we remain committed
to this policy
these repeated legal barriers are madam
deputy speaker
very similar to those that we experience
with all other removal flights and we
believe that we are fully compliant with
our domestic and international
obligations and preparations for our
future flights and the next flights have
already begun
our domestic courts were off the view
that the flight could go ahead
madame deputy speaker the case for our
partnership with veranda bears repeating
we are a generous and welcoming country
as has been shown time and time again
over 20 000 people have used safe and
legal routes to come to the uk since
2015
and most recently madame deputy speaker
britons have opened their hearts and
their homes to afghan nationals and
ukraine national ukrainian nationals
but our capacity to help those in need
is severely compromised by those who
come here illegally and as we've
discussed in this house many many times
who seek to jump the queue because they
can afford to pay the people smugglers
it is illegal it is not necessary
because they are coming from other safe
countries
it is not fair either on those who play
by the rules or on the british taxpayers
who have to foot this bill
we cannot keep on spending nearly five
million pounds a day on accommodation
including that of hotels we cannot
accept this intolerable pressure on
public services and local communities it
makes us less safe as a nation because
those who come here illegally do not
have the regularized checks or even the
regular status and because evil people
smuggling gangs use the proceeds of
their ill-gotten gains to fund other
appalling crimes that undermine the
security of our country
it is also legally dangerous for those
who are smuggled
people have drowned at sea
suffocated in lorries and perish
crossing territories
the in the humane decent and moral
response to all of this is simply not to
stand by and let people down or to be
sold into slavery or to be smuggled but
to stop this
and with that madam deputy speaker
inaction is not an option or at least
not a morally responsible one
this is as i've said repeatedly a
complex long-standing problem
the global asylum system is broken and
between 80 to 100 million people are now
displaced and others are on the move
seeking better economic opportunities
and an international problem requires
international solutions
the uk rwan the uk and rwanda have shown
the way forward by working together
and this partnership sends a clear
message that illegal entry will not be
tolerated madam deputy speaker while
offering a practical humane way forward
for those who arrive to the uk by
illegal roots
it has saddened me madame deputy speaker
to see rwanda so terribly misrepresented
introduced in his century
it is another example of how all too
often critics not only don't know what
they're speaking about but seek to
vilify another international country
that has a good track record when it
comes to refugees and stepping up to
international responsibilities the
random adam deputy speaker is a safe and
secure country with an outstanding track
record of supporting refugees and asylum
seekers and indeed we are proud that we
are working together proud that the uk
is investing in rwanda and helping that
great country to thrive i'm proud that
those who are relocated to rwanda will
have an opportunity to thrive as well
they will will be given generous support
including language skills vocational
training and help with starting their
own businesses or finding employment
but of course i'm afraid and deputy
speaker the usual suspects
with the blessings of honourable and
right honourable members opposite have
set thought to camp
set out the thought and even campaign
against these efforts and with that
madam deputy speaker the will of the
british people
it would be wrong to issue a running
commentary over ongoing cases but madam
deputy speaker i would like to say this
this government will not be deterred
from doing the right thing we will not
be put off by the inevitable legal last
minute challenges nor we will allow mobs
madam deputy speaker to block removals
we will not stand idly by and let
organize crime gangs who are despicable
in their nature and their conduct evil
people treat human beings as cargo
we will not accept that we have no right
to control our borders madam deputy
speaker we will do everything necessary
to keep this country safe and we will
continue our long and proud tradition of
helping those in genuine need
now many of us have met refugees both
abroad and on british soil and listen to
the stories that are quite frankly
chilling and heartbreaking but of course
it suits the benches opposite to pretend
that this side of the house doesn't care
but madame deputy speaker as you refer
to in the earlier point of order this on
this side of the house such accusations
are a grotesque slur
and let me tell you madam deputy speaker
what is truly chilling is listening to
opponents on going on about how awful
this policy is while offering no
practical solutions our lives are being
lost helping develop safe and legal
rules to this country for those who
really need them is absolutely at the
heart of this government's work and
having overseen efforts to bring to the
uk thousands of people in absolute need
including from hong kong syria
afghanistan and ukraine and i am the
first to say that controlled immigration
is good for our country outstanding for
our country including that by refugees
but madam deputy speaker we simply have
to focus on the support of those who
need it the most and not those who have
picked the uk as a destination over a
safe country like france
and it is no use pretending that they
are fleeing persecution when they are
traveling from a safe country because
our capacity to help is not infinite and
public support for the asylum system
will be fatally undermined if we do not
act and along with the critics the
critics of the migration and economic
development partnership have no
alternative proposal to deal with
uncontrolled immigration and like on so
many other issues the party's opposite
the labour party and the snp are on the
wrong side of the argument and we will
only see with their arguments public
trust in the system being corroded that
is irresponsible and utterly indifferent
to those who we seek to help and support
now madam deputy speaker i have always
said that i will look at all proposals
to reduce illegal migration um an
illegal entry to our country and even
those that the opposite benches might
prepare to put forward but we still uh
wait for them however however he says
that however fundamentally they don't
think there is a problem and that is why
they don't have a solution because they
still remain and stand for open borders
pure and simple
meanwhile this government wants to get
on with delivering not just on what the
british people want but reforming our
systems so yes so that they are firm but
equally madame deputy speaker so that
they are fair to those who pay for them
and fair on those who need our help and
support shadow home secretary yvette
cooper
thank you madam deputy speaker
this is a shambles and it is shameful
and the home secretary has no one but
herself to blame
this is not and never has been a serious
policy and she knew that when she
charted the plane
she knew that among the people she was
planning to send to rwanda on this plane
were torture and trafficking victims she
knew she didn't have a proper screening
process in place she knew that some of
them might be children so can she
confirm it was the home office itself
that withdrew a whole series of these
cases on friday and yesterday because
they knew there was a problem with these
cases that even without the european
court of human rights judgment she was
planning to send a plane with just seven
people on board because she'd had to
withdraw most of the cases at the last
minute
she knows that there is a lack of proper
asylum capacity in rwanda to make fair
decisions that as the unhcr
says
they only normally deal with a few
hundred cases a year there's normally
only one eligibility officer who
prepares the cases and that's as well as
lack of interpreters or legal advice to
ensure fair decisions now she promised
there will be extra payments to rwanda
for each person that is transferred
presumably to pay for those extra case
workers or extra support but she still
refused to tell us
how much
so what is she hiding will she tell us
now how much she promised rwanda for
each of the people she was planning to
send yesterday and how many rwandan
refugees she promised to take in return
she knows that serious concerns have
been raised about rwandan restrictions
on political freedom on the treatment of
people who are lgbt on the fact that 12
refugees were shot by the authorities in
2018 for protesting against food cuts on
the fact that there have been afghan and
syrian asylum seekers returned by rwanda
and she knows that none of those
concerns have been addressed she knows
too that the policy will not work we
need action to tackle dangerous criminal
gangs who are putting lives at risk
but she knows that her policies won't
achieve that and that is not their
objective because if it was she would
not have asked the national crime agency
whose job it is to target the criminal
gangs to draw up 20
staff cuts that is potentially a
thousand people being cut from the
organization that works to tackle the
gangs so can she confirm has she asked
the nca to draw up plans for staff cuts
if she was serious she would be taking
seriously the fact that the israel
rwanda deal ended up increasing criminal
people trafficking and smuggling and
that her plan risks making things worse
and if it was she would be working night
and day to get a better joint plan with
france to crack down on the gangs and to
stop the boat being put into the water
in the first place but she isn't because
her relationship with french ministers
has totally broken down if she was
serious about tackling illegal migration
illegal economic migration or cutting
the bills for people in hotels she would
be speeding up home office decision
making so refugees can get support and
those who aren't can be returned home
instead her decisions have totally
collapsed from 28 000 a year to just 14
000 decisions a year fewer than belgium
the netherlands never mind germany or
france and she's so badly failing to
take those basic decisions she is trying
to pay a country thousands of miles away
to take decisions for us instead how
shameful does that make us look around
the world
if our home office cannot take those
basic decisions she knew about problem
after problem with her policy she knows
this is unworkable unethical and won't
stop the criminal gangs but yet she
still went ahead and spent half a
million pounds chartering a plane she
never expected to fly she still went
ahead and wrote a 120 million pound
check to rwanda with a promise of more
to come and she still went ahead because
all she really cares about is picking
fights and finding someone else to blame
this isn't a long-term plan it is a
short term
everyone can see it it's not a serious
policy it's shameless posturing and she
knows it it's not building consensus
it's just pursuing division it is
government by gimmick it's not in the
public interest it's just in their
political interest and what are they
prepared to trash along the way people's
lives our basic british values of
fairness decency and common sense and
the reputation of our nation our country
is better than this we have a long
tradition of hard work and stepping up
to tackle problems not to offload them
to tackle the criminal gangs who put
lives at risk and to do right by
refugees that is what she should be
doing now and not these shambles that is
putting our country to shame
madame deputy speaker well i always look
forward to these exchanges in the house
it's fair to say um primarily primarily
because well perhaps if you'd like to
listen to them as well let me just
respond by saying um as a point of
education if i may for the honourable
lady opposite um we're not the only
country in the world to be adopting this
approach um it's fair to say um the
right honourable lady may be aware madam
deputy speaker that it's an approach you
have adopted um through their eu
transfer mechanism to rwanda um and
denmark themselves are in the process
denmark themselves are already in the
process of looking at this but she
raises a number of points which are also
factually incorrect um i'll come to you
shortly um if you don't mind
that the purpose of the work that we are
doing is absolutely madam deputy speaker
to break the business model of the
people's smugglers and it's a shame
actually that the party opposite you
know run down the national crime agency
because actually again
actually calm down just calm down a
second because actually it's you know
it's the uk intelligence community that
are working together tackling the people
smugglers upstream along with the way in
which we invest in upstream programs to
tackle the people smugglers but madam
deputy speaker i've got more to say on
this of course because the members
opposite keep speaking about asylum
seekers that have traveled from iran
iraq and other countries but of course
they've come from france madame deputy
speaker i say country they haven't come
from iraq they come from france in the
same way the ladies opposite says
they've come from syria they've come
from france they've paid people
smugglers and they claim they don't
claim that it's immoral to send people
back to european countries where their
claims can be considered there it is
literally magnum deputy speaker the
logic of the opposition seems to be that
rwanda is a wonderful country good
enough to host international summits and
world dignitaries but not for people to
be relocated there as our global
partnership has demonstrated and they
know that people are dying in the
channel but they simply do not have a
single workable solution between them
and they are choosing sides here while
this government has committed to
pioneering a way forward and of course
the party opposites are now clutching at
straws when they come to speaking about
money but of course you cannot put a
price
on lives that are lost and we believe in
saving lives and breaking the people
smuggling model and of course madam
deputy speaker when it comes to the um
claims the legal claims that i think the
honourable lady was referring to um
pre-action protocol nrm claims i do not
remember the lady opposite the shadow
home secretary you know making these
points in this sort of synthetic type of
hypothetical rage when she occupied the
season of previous labor government
where they brought in acts and powers
and past the 1999 act the 2002 act the
2004 act um basically to remove people
with no legal basis to be in this
country and these are the same powers
that we are using to remove individuals
with no legal right to be in these
countries and of course these are
exactly the same powers that only
recently and again today she was saying
that could be used if we hadn't left the
eu and yet again the honorable lady the
party opposite talks about the policy
being unworkable and and extraordinart
but it can't be both because clearly
we've said from the outset we have said
from the outset that this is a
partnership based on working with rwanda
and if i may madam deputy speaker
there is nothing more
humane than turning a blind eye to those
that are being smuggled not just across
the channel
but also in lorries and we have a global
collective responsibility to work with
international partners which clearly the
party opposite have shut the door firmly
on doing
[Applause]
[Music]
so mike penny
marshmallow speaker can i
say from the outset that i know the
shadow
uh sacramento state very well and she's
much better than some of those comments
that she came out with today much better
what i say to the home secretary
this country has and as a child i was in
school when people came from
vietnam and from hong kong previously
and from africa
but this is different this parliament is
supreme our courts have said this is
right this is what the british people
want us to do control immigration come
across in those boats so how is it right
that this court is overruled all of our
courts and this parliament yeah yeah my
humble madam deputy speaker makes a very
some very very important points first of
all he speaks to the generosity of our
country and i stand by that and i think
this government's record speaks very
very strongly in terms of supporting
people from afghanistan syria hong kong
um ukraine um and the thousands hundreds
of thousands of people that we have
supported and he rightly madame deputy
speaker speaks about our domestic courts
in the same way in which i refer to my
statement and i think it is important to
say
that um and to note that the courts have
not challenged legality of our policy
and in fact madame deputy speaker i'd
like to take this moment to do something
that um the party opposites will not do
which is pay tribute to our officials in
the home office both in country and here
that have worked on developing the
country program um evidencing the
legalities of the policy but also um the
way we work with rwanda actually as a
country in terms of their own capability
and capacity to house people and these
arguments have been challenged in the
courts and they've been well heard in
the courts if i may just make one final
point though what is concerning um of
course is that our domestic courts have
been very very transparent in their
decision making and the way in which
they communicated their verdicts from
the high court supreme court and also
the court of appeal madam deputy speaker
it is concerning obviously about the
opaque nature in which last night's
appeal was conducted by the european
court of human rights in the way in
which they informed the uk government
around one individual and of course it's
right that we spend time now going back
to that court to actually get the
grounds upon which they made their
decision
thank you spokesperson georgie mcdonald
yeah thank you madam deputy speaker
my party continues to deplore this
unworkable illegal and immoral policy
and
it does nothing to stop smugglers
and it commits it inflicts serious harm
on victims despite the home secretary's
cloud cuckoo land description of it so
we wholeheartedly welcome the
cancellation of this flight and we
condemn the reckless approach that the
home secretary has taken to taxpayers
money and more importantly to the rule
of law and can i take a moment to
commend in fact the lawyers involved for
their incredible work in the face of
some utterly inappropriate commentary
from the top of government and can i ask
the home secretary to tell her
colleagues to heed the call from the law
society in the background so and stop
attacks on legal professionals who are
simply doing their job
because madame didn't speak it's not the
lawyers who caused this flight to be
cancelled nor any court
this fight was stopped because of the
stench of yet more government illegality
and even it was even the most ardent
supporters of this dreadful policy must
recognize that there is to put it mildly
massive jubaity over its lawfulness
unhcr guardians of the refugee
convention are clear that it is in
breach so to seek to press ahead before
the courts have concluded that issue
either way was a reckless waste of
taxpayer money and shows again this
government's total regard for the rule
disregard for the rule of law
so the home sector should call this off
now and wait for that court drilling
that is all we are asking in the
meantime and she should start answering
the basic questions that we did not get
answers to on monday about oversight
about age assessments about screening
for torture survivors and trafficking
victims this is a dreadful mess
finally madame david speaker inevitably
this pitiful policy failure will now
wrongly be blamed by the usual suspects
in the european convention on human
rights so will the home secretary
recognise what the prime minister
previously said about the convention
being a great thing and will she
recognize its importance for devolution
for the good friday agreement for the
trade and corporation agreement and call
off the agitators in her party who want
the uk to follow russia and belarus
through the exit door and on to pariah
state status
thank you madam deputy speaker
well as ever um and i think tony's
important actually if i may say so in
this debate we respectfully disagree
with the honorable gentleman and his
party wholeheartedly
and that is madam deputy speaker as
we've had throughout the debates on this
subject previously but also on the
national anthem borders act as it now is
um thanks to the support that we've had
from this side of the house to deal with
smuggling and trafficking but actually
to change our laws is it it's quite
clear madame deputy speaker that the
party opposite would like to see all
removals and all deportations
irrespective of their bases full stop
and that is obviously their policy and
they would like open borders but i think
it is important i think it is important
madam deputy speaker if i just put on
the record um because this is important
that the european court of human rights
did not rule that the policy or removals
were unlawful
um but they actually prohibited the
removal of three of those on the flight
last night that was at the end
so
and if i may say so we have asked for
that ruling in writing so we're waiting
for that um but those uh prohibitions um
are different to the other
other claims that came up from lawyers
um very last minute actually yesterday
and i think it is also important to
recognize that the first ruling then
provoked those solicitors involved um to
then go back to the cause to then apply
for more injunctions for the remaining
people on the manifest so i think it's
important madam deputy speaker to take a
absolutely proportionate and measured
approach before all parties opposites
start to condemn a policy that actually
the courts have not ruled as unlawful
madam deputy speaker last november i
stood on dover seafront and i mourned 27
people who were drowned in the english
channel
of those people who'd been traveling in
these small boats these unseaworthy
vessels seven were women one was a
teenager and one was a seven year old
child
in addition up to 166 people are feared
to have lost their lives or are missing
across the channel
people who were safe already they were
safe in france
overnight many of my constituents have
got in touch with me
they are anguished at developments that
have occurred to stop effective action
to tackle the crossings can i urge my
right honourable friend to continue to
do everything possible to bring an end
to these dangerous journeys and can i
ask her what representations she has
received from the party opposite
supporting action to bring these
crossings to an end and save lives
thank my um honourable friend um for the
very thoughtful way in which she's made
her points but also asked her question
um this afternoon and in particular i do
want to pay tribute to her and also to
her constituents because they're on the
front line and madam deputy speaker i've
spent a great deal of time um both in my
honourable friends constituency and with
her and with the professionals in her
constituency
not just from border force not just on
the front line on the coast but also her
local authority
um that do a great deal of work um when
it comes to housing providing sanctuary
providing support and i think we should
just take this moment to pay tribute to
them because they're on the front line
day in day out um it is fair to say and
also i just want to commend them for the
way in which they work with home office
officials um and our operational teams
um if i may madam deputy speaker she
speaks very very strongly and powerfully
about the lives that have been lost and
it's not just crossing the channel and i
think this house should recognize this
it's not just crossing the channel it's
crossing the mediterranean it's going
through european countries and sometimes
even parts of africa and the sahel and
the conditions are absolutely appalling
and that journey that i have just spelt
out whether it's north africa the sahel
crossing the mediterranean going to eu
member states the eu
member states are safe countries and
this is the model that we have to break
and it is a fact actually and we know
this through the intelligence work
through uk intelligence network that a
lot of these gangs are basing european
member states and so while i can't speak
in more detail madam deputy speaker
about the wider work that's taken place
there's a lot of good cooperation solid
cooperation actually led by this
government that has spurred action in eu
member states to deal with the smuggling
gangs and actually to go after the
smugglers and make sure that they're
prosecuted
chair of the home affairs select
committee dame diana johnson madam
deputy speaker the permanent secretary
refused to sign off the rwanda policy on
the basis of the lack of evidence of
value for money for the taxpayer and
it's only the second time in 30 years
that the most senior civil servant in
the home office had to be ordered by the
home secretary to implement a policy so
in light of those concerns about wasting
public money
can the home secretary confirm that on
top of the payment of 120 million pounds
to rwanda the taxpayer will also now be
picking up the half million pound cost
of the flight last night and all
subsequent chartered planes whether they
take off or not and whether the
additional payments to rwanda for people
that they are expecting to arrive
will be paid whether or not they
actually arrived speak if i may say so
first of all um when it came to our
accounting officer advice we should put
this always into the context at simon
costa soaring across the united kingdom
and have been for many many years
because of the number of people that are
coming here illegally and the costs and
the strain that that puts on
particularly during the pandemic madame
deputy and if i may the right honourable
lady will know this because this is
something that has been discussed at
select committee many many times in her
as chair and when she was on the
committee when the um run on lady on the
front bench was chair of the committee
about covered impacts on asylum
specifically now she's also asked about
payments i will not we don't um speak
about operational um
costs right now
for a range of reasons a range of
reasons because quite frankly yes it is
taxpayers money primarily because of
commercial sensitivities in terms of how
we run our operations and she will also
recognize as well i think the house
should recognize when we have mob rule
turning up to thwart our charter flights
and some of them have ended up in courts
before as well
it is right that we keep our commercial
operators
um and their confidentiality and the way
in which they work um
with the home office but she has asked
about the payment mechanisms to rwanda
as part of the partnership deal and we'd
be very happy to drop her a line and
share that information with her
[Music]
thank you man
people who are trafficked into this
country are duped or co-hurst
are exploited for sexual or labor
purposes
people who have smuggled into this
country willingly pay to do so and come
for economic purposes
the first of victims and deserve the
protection of the modern slavery act
the second are not
and deserve no protection from the
modern slavery act madam deputy speaker
that is being abused by people who are
coming across
in small boats
i hope the home secretary can sort this
out
well if you speak if i may um i'd
actually like to thank my honorable
friend for his his work on this issue
he's a very very committed and
passionate advocate and also for the way
in which he's actually worked with us in
the home office on many of these
challenging issues there is a difference
between trafficking and smuggling and he
himself is very very aware of some of
the issues that have
have been materially rising over a
number of number of years in fact which
thwart the removal and deportations not
just to people that come to our country
illegally but also foreign national
offenders as well and he is referring to
the national referral mechanism and many
of the challenges there that are now
used and with intent it's fair to say um
by some of these specialist law firms
when it comes to the claims that are
being made i look forward to continuing
to work with him because clearly it's in
our interest in our national interest to
ensure that we have the right safeguards
in place for people that need our help
and support and that's what our modern
day slavery act is about but we cannot
allow people to exploit it for the wrong
moves
as carmichael
and deputy speaker why does the home
secretary say as she does in her
statement
it is no use pretending they are fleeing
persecution when they are not
the home secretary will be aware that
home office figures tell us that 98 of
those who make the channel crossing
claim asylum
the same home office figures tell us
that 64
of asylum applications are granted at
first instance and that rises to almost
80 percent after appeal
so there are only three options here
either the home secretary in demonizing
these people is a making an incorrect
statement
or else the
home office figures are incorrect or
else the home office is granting asylum
applications to people who are not
fleeing persecution
which is it
deputy speaker if i may there's a fourth
option which if i may to the right of a
gentleman say that he is wrong on all
counts because it is a fact madam deputy
speaker that the individuals coming over
the channel are coming from a safe
country which is france and with that of
course and with that of course well he
will be aware
no he will be aware through the debates
that we've had in this house on our act
of parliament nationalism borders bill
um the changes that are being made to
immigration courts and tribunals to stop
the repeated claims that go through the
cause to actually speed up processes and
actually bring the scrutiny that's
needed to stop claim after claim we've
just spoken about the exploitation of
our system that we have to stop that is
effectively part of the measures and the
changes that this government are
determined to bring in as well as madame
deputy speaker the long-term reform of
fire asylum system which he and his
party and the bench's opposite voted
against
kevin holland
speaker
in the absence of any practical workable
policies on this from the opposition i
absolutely support her policy on rwanda
i also support her policy on the
establishment of reception centers in
the uk rather than assam seekers being
housed in hotels but does she agree
those reception centers have to be in
the right location so they don't present
an unfair or undue burden on any one
community
including the 600 people who live in
lincoln news who are expecting intake of
up to 1
500 young single men right in the center
of that village does she agree that
policy should be reconsidered my name as
a deputy speaker and i can i just give
my thanks to the honourable gentleman
because we've been discussing this for
some time and working together on this
and it's incredibly important
particularly on behalf of his
constituents and he is raised
with great candor
some of the challenges that he feels his
constituents will face and madame deputy
speaker with that i have committed to
work with the on-board gentleman because
reception centers are the right way
forward there's no doubt about that so
much so madame deputy speaker i think
the house be interested to know that the
european commission has actually been
paying for eu member states to build
reception centers um and with that of
course up to um 500 million euros and
even more than that um but with that of
course mad objectively speaker we have
to have the right provisions and the
right facilities within these reception
centers and that is exactly what we are
working to achieve
thank you madam deputy speaker
last week i finally received a response
to an immigration query that my office
sent last august
i have an asylum seeker who's waited 18
months
just for an interview he still hasn't
had and many constituents desperately
looking for passports which failed to
arrive and yet the home secretary is
spending millions and millions of
taxpayers money on a policy which is as
unworkable as it is inhumane so why
doesn't the home secretary put the work
in fix the issues in her department of
process and resource instead of hiding
her incompetence behind desperate
refugees
um i'm going to very very politely
disagree with the honourable ladies
for a change um and i think it's
important to say i mean she's asked
about the asylum case she will know
perfectly well bear in mind her party
supported being locked down throughout
the pandemic for even longer than this
side of the house did that asylum
decisions were not being made during the
pandemic and those interviews were not
being granted because many of them were
face to face and now we have reformed
the system to actually put many more
online and things of that nature that is
the nature of the pandemic and we are
building upon that work and she will
know that and it's a shame she she voted
against asylum reforms the new plan for
immigration um madame deputy speaker she
mentioned passports she i'm sure would
welcome the resources in people and
staff around passports and the work that
has taken place with the passport agency
and the increase in demand that's more
blue passports this year that'll be
issued um compared to previous years and
that is something if i may madam deputy
speaker i pass the opposite light to run
down civil servants that's quite clear
in the hard work of people in the
homeless um we are if i may they can
stop the finger-pointed we work together
as a team to deliver for the british
people it's such a shame that the party
opposite constantly votes against these
changes and these missions
dr andrew morrison
in the early 1950s
notably with the involvement of british
lawyers for very good reason
but does she agree with me that last
night's decision
undermined the original purpose
of the convention by the court
and that the court stands the very real
risk of losing the confidence of the
british people as it seeks to undermine
our domestic legal structures
if i may my runnable friend makes makes
a very very strong and important point
um and and in fact we as i've touched on
already um from the high court to the
supreme court and the court of appeal um
our policy and there will there will be
more legal action we know this um our
policy has not been found to be unlawful
there are very very strong submissions
based upon the evidence actually the
work that's taken place in country in
rwanda on the efficacy not just of the
policy but the delivery of the policy in
country that is absolutely right um i
think the public will be surprised
there's no doubt about that but madam
deputy speaker i think it's important to
be cautious right now because of legal
proceedings just to finally say that we
clearly are in touch with the
european court of human rights because
we do want to
get their judgment their decision in
writing which we have not had yet and as
i said earlier on it is concerning when
the british courts have been so public
in terms of providing their summary and
their positions um that last night was
very opaque in decision-making
well the pretty uh pretty patella the
home secretary uh making a statement to
the house about the uh possible
deportation of people to rwanda being
challenged there by the shadow home
secretary yvette cooper um pretty patel
saying that she believes the flights
could go ahead that the domestic courts
have said that they could go ahead
talked about uh the 20 000 of people who
have used the safe and legal routes to
get into the uk and the cost of keeping
those that you would like to send to
rwanda in the uk ivette cooper in
opposition saying that this is a
shambles and it is shameful
let's bring in our deputy political
editor sam coates he's here
pretty darn getting quite a hard time in
the comments quite combative though
coming back there
that's right although i think um she was
prepared for the fight in fact i think
the government broadly leaning into the
idea of a fight
uh over this all the way along ever
since the rwanda policy was first
announced what six weeks ago or so
you've had a government making clear
that their view it was going to be a
tough fight there were going to be legal
challenges uh but they would press ahead
of it and sort of wanting to almost make
a lot of uh the back and forth over
trying to make this happen it raises the
salience of this issue uh it means that
more people notice it uh and it makes it
look like the government are um uh
fighting for people hard as you were
pointing out earlier uh the polling's
pretty evenly split it's not a slight
advantage for uh those who think that
the rwandan policy is a good thing but
uh it's described in government by some
as the perfect wedge issue in other
words it motivates conservative voters
uh to come out uh and and vote for them
and uh is quite off-putting for uh uh
for some labor voters um who they hope
might stay at home so uh it is a a a a
fight pretty patel uh prepared for that
interesting she was choosing to do two
things i thought first of all lecture
quite a lot of mps on tone particularly
those who are more critical
and secondly
she went out of her way to praise
officials not something that you often
associate with uh pretty patel she's had
many a run-in with some of her senior
colleagues at the home office but today
uh it was all smiles with her friend
with her friends in the home office and
those uh in border force that are
implementing this policy
uh we've we've had word from uh the
prime minister's spokesman in the last
few minutes saying that the government's
keeping all options on the table
regarding the european court of human
rights including possible legal reforms
but also uh
us talking about the eu and northern
ireland and saying that they're going to
respond in due course and they're
disappointed that the eu is bringing
this legal action that they announced
this morning uh that's right i mean i
think that the the northern ireland uh
legal action is pretty much priced in uh
boris johnson saying on monday uh that
it would be an overreaction uh if we
ended up in some kind of trade war i
think all of those uh meaningful
consequences a lot further down uh at
the track that we are at the moment so
the government trying to dial down i
think a little bit of the rhetoric after
monday but just uh on the point about
the european court of human rights that
i think is where the most interesting
action is politically today obviously it
was an echr judgment last night that
meant that that flight didn't take off
uh today you've had some pressure from
back bench tory mps but what's been
interesting has been where the
government has been all day long so if
you listened to
therese coffee on skye earlier today she
didn't seem to think that there was any
chance uh of britain pulling out of the
uh convention on human rights guy operan
uh a more moderate tory mp echoing that
he's a minister he said i can't see us
uh doing that then in the last few
moments boris johnson spokesman
reiterating all options are on the table
when it comes to uh the european
convention of human rights and the court
that goes uh with it uh so so right at
the top of government first of all uh no
clear line but lastly boris johnson and
his immediate lieutenants uh leading
into this idea of yet another very big
fight
okay sam thanks very much
well let's return uh to what we're
talking about there uh the european
union launching fresh legal action
against the uk in response to boris
johnson's plans to override the brexit
treaty concerning trade in northern
ireland talking in the last couple of
hours the european commission vice
president marissevcovich called the
actions illegal and said they'd cast a
shadow over the eu's overall cooperation
with the uk
let there be
no doubt
there is no legal
nor political justification whatsoever
for unilaterally changing an
international agreement
opening the door to unilaterally
changing an international agreement is a
breach of international law as
well so let's called a spade expect this
is illegal
well the northern ireland protocol is an
agreement between the uk government and
the european union which came into force
in january 2021 it was designed to
prevent a hard border and customs checks
on the island of ireland when the uk
left the eu the prime minister boris
johnson agreed that checks would take
place on some goods traveling across the
irish sea from britain the protocol is
backed by a majority of northern
ireland's political representatives
excuse me but strongly opposed by
unionists who don't like being treated
differently from the rest of the uk
part of the government's plan to fix the
protocol involves setting up a green
lane between great britain and northern
ireland
there would be a red lane for eu trade
enabling goods to flow freely around the
uk whilst protecting the eu single
market
well our europe correspondent adam
parsons is in brussels uh so what
happens now adam
yeah good question well the the legal
action that started today requires the
uk government to respond uh within a
couple of months so we'll see what
happens with that there were these three
legal actions now in process against the
uk one of them had already been started
then it was frozen as a sign
of goodwill i think it's probably quite
illustrative of the fact that it has now
been
unfrozen just as uh relations between
the eu and the uk go back into the
freezer uh and a couple of new ones have
been open one is about border controls
another one is about data in the minds
of the european union these are all
breaches of uh of the agreement that
have been carried out by the united
kingdom but i think these are also sort
of shots across the bow interesting that
today
in terms of that rwanda policy and the
northern ireland protocol this is the
case i think of the eu trying to put
focus on what it says
is the united kingdom's rather renegade
view of international law uh do you
really want to be seen as a nation that
does not take international law
seriously in the words of one eu
official that i spoke to but of course
the person we heard from most uh was
maroszepic today the the chief
negotiator
uh the vice president i'd say a man who
even though you talked to uk officials
said i think he's a person that they can
they can deal with he's not a person
given to flights or fury today though he
came out with that heir of a
disappointed parent i have to say
somebody who gave that air of look i'm
not
angry with you uk i'm just disappointed
that you haven't gone along with what
you said you would do he said that there
was a negotiated settlement to be done
even with something of an arch of an
eyebrow refer to it as an oven ready
deal but what are the political
background to this
why now why this and why these pointed
references to the british government
that was something that i put to maris
sefkovic have a listen to what he said
there are lots of people here in
brussels who think that the european
commission is being played by the
british government for its own domestic
concerns
do you have trust in the good faith of
boris johnson and liz trust
and if not were you tempted to go harder
and further with the legal proceedings
that you've taken against the british
government or do you still have those
options up your sleeve thank you very
much for that question of course
i think our today's action the fact that
we have to start the legal proceedings
and legal action against
our ally against
our partner
in this very difficult times where we
face together the global
thank you very much for that question of
course
i think our today's action the fact that
we have to start the legal proceedings
and legal action against
our ally against
our partner
in this very difficult times where we
face together the global challenges is
pretty telling what the level of of the
trust
we have
and the answer to that is that the level
of trust is pretty much
below the ground so what happens next is
i have to say diplomatically both sides
will continue to say they're on the
right both sides will say the other one
is being intransigent both sides will
say they are ready uh to renegotiate and
both will say that the other ones are
not really putting anything new on the
table we have a lot of vitriol a lot of
words coming out but no real sign of